you're watching a swipe special from the
web summit in Dublin coming up on the
show this week going to be the next tech
billionaire we meet the startup hopefuls
with big ambitions growing pictures left
right and center would test out a
panoramic camera ball dynamic eyewear
one company is hoping to change how you
see the world and show me the money we
get tips for success from a director at
the world's largest crowd funding
platform hello from the web summit one
of the most influential tech events we
made it here from London this week
despite the foggy weather and so did
thousands of others from all over the
world this place is huge and it's
teeming with startups all competing for
publicity and financial backing and
there are plenty of industry speakers
here to inspiring the new generation so
what does it take to be the next big
thing in tech is Chris
the organizers call this the world's
largest gathering of startups more than
2,000 tech entrepreneurs are here at web
summit to show off their products we are
world's worst digital time capsules and
these are one of our products that
essentially allow people to connect to
our platform live and track down every
step of the way goodnight thinking about
it the largest affordable industrial 3d
printer the world ever seen it's 30
times bigger than that desktop printer
you may have seen in the local school
get a clue two and two two two two and a
half times the cost ability app is a
free app that will help people with
disabilities navigate public spaces as
well as find safe reliable services and
employment opportunities a select few of
these companies are invited to sell
their ideas to a panel of judges in a
pitching competition winner is simply
one of this year's winning entries is an
employee scheduling app called biz
employ
currently awards are a huge part for us
we don't have the biggest marketing
budget in the world we don't invest
hugely and paid advertising like our
money gets directed towards acquiring
new customers through word of mouth than
through reseller and partnership
programs but also building the product
and they have so what's the next step
for a new startup they might want to get
advice from someone like this man John
Collison is the co-founder of online
payment service stripe in tech terms his
company's what's known as a unicorn
that's a start-up worth more than a
billion dollars I think if you look at
the best products and the most
successful product they generally don't
always succeed due to doing a whole lot
of PR or doing a whole lot of page
marketing or anything like that I think
the best products spread by word of
mouth and in particular are kind of good
enough and new enough and a big enough
step forward that people really want to
talk about them and people really want
to share their share them with our
friends if be simply were to take off it
would be something of a rarity as far as
successful European startups are
concerned nearly three quarters of
today's unicorns are US companies
however that balance is improving what
you need to see in Europe he's a few
companies actually going all the way and
not be acquired in the urine stage and I
think we seeing that now with companies
like Spotify like transferwise like a DN
like BlablaCar so you see these
companies actually today being worth
over a billion and I hope in a few years
being worth like maybe in the 5 10
billion range regardless of where they
come from the harsh reality is that most
new startups fail but at least they're
trying to get noticed Chris Cregan Sky
News at the web summit in Dublin
still to come how to make your
crowdfunding campaign work i chat to one
of indy go-go's directors or one of the
things that really hit us and we arrived
here at the web summit was the sheer
number of ideas from different startups
it will be impossible to show you them
all but we have selected a couple take a
look up Bjorn's camera ball here tell us
about this so this is a camera
consisting of 36 individual cameras and
there's a total resolution of one road
egg megapixels so these are all mini
cameras correct so it's like a massive
panoramic view that you would get a 360
about 30 60 I can you throw it that's
the special thing about the camera you
can screw it into the air and at the
highest point automatically takes a
picture tastic I have you though yeah
because it's a lot of electronics in it
battery image it's about 450 grams I
don't know that would be quite heavy
carrying that on holiday haha i carried
around it was pretty nice and pretty
easy for me but all right we'll show us
for the images that line so yes as we
were inside i wouldn't roll I say we
don't injure anybody here so just take a
picture day okay okay here we are then I
always want to smile at each one you're
gone and then I can get a preview for
the screen ah so if you have a look here
you are and then I can just turn around
or i can switch the mode so you can just
hold in your hands oh and
so this would be my view if I was the
camera ball Hey look at that there I am
that there you are Chris there Chris
holding the microphone cameraman Kieran
oh that's very cool so tell me how
funding is going so we we started with
some angel investors and did a
crowdfunding campaign on IndieGoGo which
was the most successful campaign on
continental Europe at that time
pagination million and the boring angel
investors but as always as a harbor
startup you're looking for more funding
to scale to grow China a lot of
competition here a lot of people here in
general and yeah but I think we have an
amazing product and people are coming to
our RP to us so it's pretty good thanks
for talking to ask you on thank you very
much yeah now you're looking at some
very special sunglasses with us as
project manager Christina and these are
called scuba is that back yeah that's
right that's right what why dakota start
what does that mean what do they do it's
gotta actually means shadow in Swedish
yay so what did you is its electrical
sunglasses as you can actually adjust
attempt in your sunglasses adjust the
shading yeah exactly china anne house
you mud because that's been around for
Waller how that works oh yeah it really
about so these are
so you can have them either
automatically or you can also change
them in your home I will not okay
exactly I adjusting Shay just a change
Oh can I try them on I've worried are
you going to adjust the show you just
for you absolutely
I mean they're quite comfortable I mean
they just thought I am just wearing
sunglasses that feels like where's I
mutters oh we can go pro that was just
my phone yeah just bluetooth and they're
nice so you can be outdoors you just get
your phone out and adjust absolutely
yeah and also you can have them in the
automatic mode as well what does that
mean it means we have an ambient light
sensor just here yeah so you can
actually have them in automatics and
they will change for you so they will
see when you come out in the light and
they wrinkle chart it was just they'll
just do it they'll just do all that for
you now the thing with wearables I find
is that they don't always look very cool
no and you can have some amazing tech
but it might just look a bit conking a
bit geeky so how did you go about
designing these because I quite like
them I don't think I mean I don't really
like mr. chief Jung Joo hee hee do they
ok thanks Tina so how did you go about
designing them so we wanted to have a
lifestyle product and not like a
wearable wearable we'd all it takes so
it was important for us to start with an
actual design and go from there as you
can see there's no like porch or
anything on them
you can't actually tell they are smart
or with that nationality until you
actually see them how much are they
would they be we're not selling them at
the moment yeah prototypes and so would
they be I can't tell you for sure oh
yeah will they be more or less expensive
than a pair of designer sunglasses I
would probably say kind of the same I
your sunglasses yeah brilliant thank I'm
gonna hand these back to you carefully
thank you for showing us we're joined
now by anastasiya Emmanuel the European
director of indy gogo thanks for joining
us crowdfunding its massive every week
on swype we talk about something to do
with crowdfunding would you say we're in
the middle of a crowdfunding revolution
I don't think it's a revolution because
the industry has already gone through
that I feel like the revolution is
happening and I see it more of a
crowdfunding evolution the industry this
year is meant to be 35 and a half
billion dollars by 2025 it's 100 billion
so I feel like there's a lot of
movements as a lot of growth in do yoga
itself have seen Triple growth in
technology alone so I think the reason
that people are really excited about
crowdfunding is because also it's not
just about the product or the idea it's
about the marketing and building up that
community okay so let's talk about
success then if I had a campaign I
wanted it to go on IndieGoGo what tips
would you give me I would say to you
that you need to prepare preparation is
key think about it like the brownies you
have to rather longer that you work on
your campaign and you make sure that
you're ready to go the more success
you'll see from it so we tend to work
with campaigners for months or even
years before they actually launch their
campaign and you need to try and figure
out who your audience is you need to
test out your marketing message you need
to think about who the journalists that
are gonna write about it how am I gonna
get in touch with Gemma to get it on Sky
News wife say hi jebo hi jebo
storytelling is really important so if
you look at a campaign like gebo which
was the world's first human robot the
founder actually spoke just here at web
summit today and you look at their video
it's amazing it's this robot but the
video is so human it's so imperfect you
watch it and you kind of fall in love
with jebo and they did really well they
raised three point
seven million dollars in their campaign
and they've gone on to raise tens of
millions of dollars outside and they're
going to deliver the product next year
but I think what really captured
people's imagination is the storytelling
of what not jebo the robot could do but
him as a human and being part of your
family does it bother you when you see
people trying to use crowdfunding to get
money to buy a house or cover their
student fees like it's an easy way of
getting money it's definitely not easy
that for birthing there's much easier
ways than getting money than running a
crowdfunding campaign it takes a lot of
work but IndieGoGo was found in 2008 to
try and tackle the problem of access to
capital you know banks weren't lending
and people couldn't raise money for
their ideas so all these amazing ideas
and things that should have happened
that weren't coming to life because of a
lack of access to capital so I
absolutely do not feel annoyed or
frustrated when I see someone raising
money for a good cause or a scholarship
or a creator creative idea or an
entrepreneurial vision I think
crowdfunding is a totally blank canvas
you can go out and raise money for
whatever you feel empowered to do so
thanks it's open source
well that's it from Dublin take a look
at Sky News on mobile and iPad for more
from the web summit you again next week
bye bye